oh that that's gonna require a sip of
wine Leah that's a really tough question
[Music]
okay so we're gonna have a really
interesting session of ask mr. wonderful
today because of one of my most I guess
favorite places I'm in an FP Joran watch
boutique now I don't know if you know
the brand FP Jordan is one of the
greatest watchmakers on earth think of
Picasso while Picasso was alive so when
you buy an FP Jorn you're buying a
Picasso painting before he's dead
anyways I thought it would be a great
inspirational place to answer some
questions so by the way I bought a new
watch today this blue F P Jordan and I'm
just I'm going to start crying I love it
so much I'm 28 located in Vancouver
without a degree I have two years of
experience in college and a few years
working as an experienced in sales
my question is what would be my best
shot of making it into the financial
industry am I too old to giving it a
shot
Aaron you're never too old to give it a
shot but let me tell you something first
of all let's deal with the first part of
your question I tell people the way it
is because in business it's kind of
binary it's black and white either you
make money or you lose it and you
shouldn't lie about that because the
markets gonna come and bite your hiney
anyways if you don't get it right and I
just tell them the truth if they don't
like it too bad I'm trying to save their
money not their feelings now let's move
on regarding you here's what I've
learned in life it's really good to
apprentice and learn from masters that
know a lot more and have experience that
you don't have if you like financial
services you've got to go work for
somebody in financial services you have
to be an intern somewhere they're gonna
treat you like crap they're gonna pay
you nothing
but you're going to learn something if
you can spend a year working for a
company that you aspire to actually be a
manager in or accelerate in that's a
great outcome for you know is that
insurance there's in the credit industry
is it for a bank an investment banker I
don't know it's really what you want to
do because it sounds like you want to
kind of pivot into the world of finance
the only way to play the game there
Aaron is to go work in it and learn how
tough it is and by the way they take
guys like you and they work you 20 hours
a day pay you nothing it's brutal but
you learn so much do it for a year to 18
months and then you can launch yourself
so look if you have the interest and the
desire and it sounds like you do listen
to what I just said
go be an intern and good luck to you and
by the way stop your whining when you
haven't had any sleep and you're doing
seven days a week remember I told you
was gonna be that hard but it's worth it
you'll learn insecure about how I look
and is handicapping me from reaching my
full potential
I just want to improve myself and be
better until I can take my business to
the next level but I'm too
self-conscious to take photos or even
meet new people because of my acne you
have any wisdom to provide me I really
can't I can't maintain what I'm doing
you know Erik I love the fact that
you're being honest about this issue
it clearly is bothering you let me tell
you something about how people look I
don't care if you're fat you're skinny
you're bald doesn't matter it's can you
perform can you execute if somebody
gives you a task can you deliver believe
me they don't care how you look now let
me tell you something that acne you can
get that fixed there are some great
solutions on the market it involves a
little diet and a pill you have to take
every day but maybe in your case if it's
bothering you so much you can deal with
it but don't ever think that's gonna
hold you back
people don't care what they care about
is can you work can you execute can you
meet targets in business that's all it
matters I don't care how you look can
you deliver believe me I've got people
looking pretty crazy pretty eclectic
covered in that in tattoos fish hooks
all over them I don't give a [ __ ] you
know what I like about them they're
consistent delivers they know how to
make their targets they're very very
strong and executional skills and if you
can do that nobody cares if you have
acne but if it's bothering you go get it
fixed it's not that hard to do and
there's great solutions but I like the
question that was a good one next
question is from Aaliyah so what would
you say to someone who wants to pursue
their passion in the arts who's also
very talented
dedicated to what they do but doesn't
want to risk the starving artists
stereotype oh that that's gonna require
a sip of wine Maliha that's a really
tough question let me just savor this
Montrachet a crisp Chardonnay in the
French style not oked at all just really
crispy one second now this is something
that's very difficult for everybody in
life you have to make decision pursue
your passion if it's the arts that's
often not a place where you can make
enough money to eat a big problem the
key to success in life is finding the
balance to find something you love doing
that you can actually get paid to do now
there are jobs in the arts that can
actually help you make a living curating
in a museum for example tough gig to get
pays well but really passionate for the
people that love to do that they've
become specialists in an area like
Renaissance art or sculpture or whatever
or contemporary art and they pursue that
dream and they find a way to make it
work if you really want to pursue the
arts you've got to get a job now you
know people ask me all the time what's
the solution to that in in ancient times
or even medieval times there was the
concept of patron a person that would
take you under their wing and pay for
you to be the expert in the arts there
are equivalents in modern times where
you go work for a family that may be
collecting art and they respect you as
some of them can help them curate their
decisions I'm telling you how to get a
career in the arts not easy but if
you're really good at it and you can
find it baked at all a family that's
collecting art that wants you to help go
do the the hard work of going and
finding and dealing with dealers and
trying to find pieces that would fit the
curated a shion's of that family I'm
just giving you some suggestions I'm
throwing it out there but that's how you
could actually make a living in
something you love the concept of the
medieval baked at home which started in
Italy actually when families like the
Medici family would say look we're going
to support the Arts and we need people
to work for us to go find great artists
that we can actually fund same idea in
modern times I hope I've helped you with
that I'm kind of inspired thinking about
it myself
it's kind of interesting I use it's a
great job if you're an artist you know
after all that I need another sip of
wine yeah anyways good luck with that
one what's next next question is from
Sean so I had saved up money for a down
payment for a house what would you
consider a safe reasonable percentage of
my income that should go towards a
mortgage I was told by someone that it
shouldn't be any more than 70% would I
make a year Sean this is a great
question and very important is for
everybody involved in deciding to
purchase a home now the biggest mistake
people make when they buy a home is they
buy a home too big because they're now
servicing something and using over half
their income after tax remember you're
servicing the mortgage after tax income
so if you're the average salary in
America is 56 thousand dollars and you
got to eat and you have to have money to
do other things with the best way to get
into homeownership is to never let the
mortgage more than 30% of your after-tax
income don't go crazy
start with 2,000 square feet 1,500
square feet something small maybe a
condo maybe a you know a semi-detached
something the biggest mistake and I
nearly do this to myself when I was
young I bought a big home really big I
couldn't afford it and I had to rent it
out to all my friends from college all
through the bedrooms and my girlfriend
said why are all these people living
with us I said well honey I can't afford
the house I paid too much for the home I
made the mistake myself I should've
bought something a lot small start small
pay down the mortgage sell it buy
something a little bigger as your salary
goes up but my rule very simple Sean not
more than 30 percent of your after-tax
income otherwise you could really screw
yourself because sometimes you lose your
job for example and that really gets
crazy you know what the house to be an
anchor a ball in a chain a piece of land
around your your your feet that's crazy
30% that's the max next question comes
from Grayson I'm a manager at 19 years
old lately I've been running into some
problems with some staff being
insubordinate when
asking them to do simple tasks I'm not
sure how to go about disciplining them
what makes it a bit awkward for me is
that I'm probably the youngest person in
my organization or one of the youngest
so often I find people disregard my
authority how do I can I go around this
the right way
raise up 19 year old manager born to
lead my friend that's what it sounds
like to me 19 years old here's the key
to being a successful manager people
don't have to like you they have to
respect you and you have to respect them
two great managers in life and I've gone
through this my career you don't have to
like the people that work for you but
you have to show them respect and they
have to reciprocate that in managing
companies it's all about respect and
it's primarily setting goals for people
and asking them to buy into those goals
and agreeing with you
that those are achievable and giving
them at least three months to go achieve
them so I wouldn't get worried about the
social impact or the concerns about
being a manager at 19 it doesn't matter
how old you are it's irrelevant it
matters if people are willing to follow
you respect you listen to you work with
you and set goals together that you both
achieve if you can do that at 19 you are
a friggin rock star my friend and I have
a sense that maybe you are but remember
shell respect and respect something that
you don't have experience because when
you're 19 you don't have any of that so
if you meet somebody that's working for
you there's a lot older respect what
they know that you don't it's all about
respect
last question comes from Clayton you
mentioned the idea as watches as
investments do you consider every
personal interest like watches an
investment or do you also go for things
that maybe aren't intended to grow in
value Clayton what a amazing question
you know I started my life always saying
why would I buy that if it's not a great
investment and for a long time that's
how I've led my life I always say I'm
not buying that because it's not a great
investment stock increase in value but
then you get married and things change
because sometimes your wife wants to
spend money on things you don't think
are a very good idea and you try and
talk them out of that or your girlfriend
or you
significant other but sometimes it's not
all about the money
it's about sharing with somebody and
letting them do what they want to do
with their time and you may be support
them and lately in my life and you know
I'm not a spring chicken anymore I've
realized that everything I spend my
money on can't be a great investment but
it can support somebody's own dreams or
interests like my kids or my wife or
whatever and I've gotten a little
loosey-goosey about it now I realize
sometimes they spend money and it's just
a total waste or is it you know what
they call that they call that marriage
they call that family they call that
kids you can't just piss away everything
you've made but you have to be a little
flexible as you get older you got to
kind of start thinking a little bit
about it's not all about just dying with
as much money as you can possibly make
although that's how I started thinking
in my early days now so by making sure I
keep my family happy and my friends
family too I just say to myself once in
a while I do this for myself these
watches these are great investments now
my wife said to me why do you own more
than one watch I don't have an answer
that was a wonderful episode of ask mr.
wonderful every every single new weapons
get crazier and more interesting I'm
loving it and hope you are let's do it
again soon
[Music]